[Music]
on this Sunday night nowhere that is
safe as the humanitarian crisis in Gaza
deepens and no one is safe in Gaza
Palestinians are being pushed to a small
remote so-called safe Zone that has no
resources and how Canada's role in a
multilateral solution remains shrouded
in
secrecy a champion for Iranian women's
rights is awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
woman life them Nar muhammed's teenage
children read the acceptance speech
smuggled from their mother's prison
cell cop 28 and the urgency to eliminate
fossil fuels young people of the world
should be very afraid but with the
conference closing in two days divisive
compromises including one by Alberta's
premere are being called
unscientific and cracking the code why
unlocking this safe in Winnipeg was far
more satisfying than its
contents global national with far an
Asser reporting tonight Colleen Christie
good evening thanks for joining us key
mediators say the chances of a new pause
in fighting between Israel and Hamas
well they're narrowing as Israeli forces
push deeper into gaza's second largest
city the war continues in full force
Benjamin Netanyahu told members of his
cabinet today the Israeli Prime Minister
rebuffed pressure to agree to a
ceasefire saying it would prevent
Israel's goal of eliminating Hamas
Israel has ordered people in con Yunis
to leave for their own safety with
reports servicing that Israeli tanks
reached the center of the city
tonight Israel's continued push means
the number of so-called safe zones in
Gaza are dwindling by the hour the World
Health Organization described the
situation as catastrophic while holding
an unusual emergency session which
called for immediate and unimpeded
access for Aid into Gaza Redmond Shannon
begins our coverage tonight at a warning
his report contains disturbing
images another father Mourns the death
of a son at Nassar Hospital in KH
unun its floors are now beds a regular
flow of the injured carried
inside at the start of Israel's ground
oper a can Yunis in southern Gaza was a
place of relative safety but the air
strikes have ramped
up and now Israel says people must leave
the center of the city as Israeli troops
fight their way in street by Street the
options for fleeing gazans are lessening
one area of Gaza that Israel says will
remain safe is here almasi by the coast
it measures just over 8 8 square kilm
this is how it compares to downtown
Toronto and downtown Vancouver the baron
Coastal area has no electricity
sanitation or running water it's not
known how many of gaza's 2.3 million
residents could be forced to flee here
as more and more people move to a
smaller and smaller
area
overcrowding combined with the lack of
adequate food water shelter and
sanitation are creating the ideal
conditions for disase to spread on
Sunday the World Health Organization
adopted a resolution calling for
immediate medical access to Gaza and an
end to attacks on hospitals Israel says
Hamas uses hospitals as bases for its
operations the impact of the conflict on
health is catastrophic the resolution
also demands that Israeli hostages and
detained Palestinians get access to
Medical Care
too access to food and clean water is
another ever growing problem for
gazin this man says he has been lining
up for hours every day for 2 weeks
before finally getting a bag of flour on
Sunday for the more than 2 million
others like him there is little end in
sight Redmond Chann and Global News
London Beyond The Siege of Gaza there
were also more skirmishes today around
the border between Israel and Lebanon
the latest in what's been daily
firefights between Hezbollah Fighters
and Israeli forces spurred by hamas's
October 7th attack the violence has
killed more than 120 people on lebanon's
side including 16 civilians on Israel's
side seven soldiers and four civilians
have died those hostilities underscore
the impact Israel's assault on Hamas is
having beyond the Gaza strip a global
diplomatic effort continues to unfold to
find a way to Halt the fighting and the
countries nearest to the crisis are
playing a key role in that initiative
and on Saturday their efforts briefly
involved a direct conversation with
Canada David Aken
[Applause]
reports on Saturday night thousands
gathered to demand the release of the
137 hostages including a Canadian woman
believed to be still held by Hamas
during the rally testimonies were
screened of several hostages who had
been
released every day there was like hell
21-year-old Maya regev says in this
video unreal fear no sleep at night
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is under intense pressure to
negotiate the release of more hostages
but ahead of a cabinet meeting Sunday
Netanyahu rebuffed international calls
for a ceasefire describing those calls
as inconsistent was supporting Israel's
war aim of eliminating Hamas but
International efforts to find peace
continue nonetheless for example the
foreign Ministers of Jordan Turkey Saudi
Arabia and the Palestinian Authority
visited the foreign capitals of each of
the permanent members of the UN Security
Council this group minus the Jordanian
foreign minister then traveled to Ottawa
Saturday to meet with prime minister
Justin Trudeau and foreign affairs
minister melino joli neither Jolie n
trudo would speak to reporters about the
meeting meanwhile the Jordanian foreign
minister Aman safadi was at a forum in
Qatar where he said Israel's war amounts
to what he said was the legal definition
of genocide what we see in Gaza is not
simply uh the killing of of innocent
people the destruction of their of their
livelihoods but we are seeing uh a
systematic effort it seems to empty Gaza
uh from its People Israel rejected that
allegation these are of course
outrageous and false accusations Israel
is fighting to defend itself from the
monsters who perpetrated the October 7th
Massacre Qatar is where several
political leaders of Hamas are based and
Qatar has been leading negotiations
between that group and Israel we will
continue pressuring the parties despite
each party aims to destroy the
others cut our hopes at consume broker
another pause in the fighting to get
more hostages out of Gaza and more Aid
into the territory David Aken Global
News
Ottawa voters in Egypt are expected to
stick to the status quo in their
presidential election the current
president Abdul fata LCC is Seeking a
third term which would hand him another
six years of power critics see the
election as a sham after nine years of
crackdowns on dissidents since LCC
assumed office the winner will be tasked
with cooling Egypt's near record
inflation and preventing spillover from
the violence between Israel and
Hamas the teenage children of imprisoned
Iranian activist Nares muhamed have
accepted the Nobel Peace Prize on her
behalf the prestigious award was
presented in Oslo today the 51-year-old
is being recognized for her work
fighting against the oppression of women
in her country in Her speech smuggled
from prison she denounced Iran's
tyrannical
government
Mohammed is currently serving a 10year
prison sentence for spreading so-called
anti-state propaganda her children have
not seen her since 2015 when they fled
Iran for
France Iran has banned Masa amini's
family from traveling to France to
receive the European Union top
humanitarian rights prize on her behalf
Amin's death in police custody in 2022
sparked Mass protests in Iran and a
global movement that rocked the Islamic
Republic she was awarded the sakarov
prize postumus in October the prize will
be presented on Tuesday her parents and
brother were stopped yesterday as they
attempted to board a flight to
France controversial libertarian Javier
Malay has officially been sworn in as
Argentina's president thousands of
attended the far-right leaders
inauguration after he led a polarizing
campaign propelled by the country's
worst economic crisis in decades he even
met Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalinski who's touring Latin America to
Garner support against Russia's Invasion
Malay has drawn many comparisons to
Donald Trump for his politics and crash
Behavior he's vowed to eliminate
Argentina's Central Bank due to
inflation and repeal abortion access
laws at one point he proposed allowing
people to sell their own
organs at least six people have been
killed in Tennessee after strong storms
and tornadoes tore through the state on
Saturday
oh oh my God more than 50 people were
injured with rescue crews searching for
other survivors most of the damage from
the severe weather was done just north
of Nashville tens of thousands of people
are still without power with just two
days remaining at the United Nations cop
28 climate Summit there's still no
consensus on the future of fossil fuels
at least 80 countries are in favor of a
first ofit kind International commitment
to end the use of oil and gas but major
energy producers including OPEC are
pushing back Heather urex West has more
on the
impass while I know we're making
progress I don't think we're
making we're making it fast enough but
time is running out for the more than
190 governments meeting in Dubai to
reach a consensus on its most divisive
issue we need realistic approaches to
tackle emission one that uh enable
economic growth OPEC nations are among
those pushing hardest against a global
agreement to end the use of fossil fuels
the latest version of negotiations
released Friday shows countries
considering several options from a
agreeing to a phase out of fossil fuels
phasing out abated fossil fuels using
things like carbon capture and storage
to no mention of a phase out at all OPEC
and the oil companies right now are
trying
to
whitewash the um crisis that has been
created by fossil fields we will not
reach uh 1.5° or even 2° if we do not
phase out fossil fuels on a very very
large
scale Canada which saw one of its worst
wild fire seasons on record this year
committed Thursday to cutting oil and
gas emissions by introducing a cap and
trade system something Alberta's Premier
is vowing to fight speaking from Dubai
Danielle Smith says she believes Canada
should focus not on phasing out fossil
fuels but on finding ways to store
carbon in the ground we've estimated at
a minimum we will be able to store a 100
billion tons of CO2 emissions so we've
got massive capacity to not only solve
Alberta's uh emissions issue but the but
the world's as well but carbon capture
as a solution has yet to be proven at
the scale required and the UN climate
science panel says it cannot be counted
on alone let's make sure that science is
our guarding star and they are saying we
need to phase out ASAP a clash between
countries as cop 28 enters its final
days Heather urex West Global News
Calgary fueling another dangerous
dictator why Venezuela wants to Annex
neighboring
Guyana Venezuela and Guyana have agreed
to a highlevel meeting next week over
the status of a disputed region between
the two South American nations at the
center of the dispute is a 60,000 Square
kilomet swath of land where massive
discoveries of offshore oil and gas have
been made last Sunday Venezuela held a
vote in which Caracus alleges 95% of the
public backed plans to Annex the region
from Guyana analysts have disputed those
figures but that hasn't stopped the
long-standing dispute from being
emboldened further this week with
Venezuela placing troops at the border
and the United States holding joint
flyover drills with Guyana Mike J
reports typically Brash and defiant
Venezuelan president Nicholas Maduro is
moving ahead with his boldest move yet
annexing a large part of neighboring
Guyana while critics suggest its a ploy
to remain in power amid skyrocketing
inflation Maduro isn't backing
down three months he says is how much
time he's willing to give Guyana to
abandon the area this is posturing it's
very dangerous posturing uh he's changed
the map the official map of Venezuela to
include esao esao comprises 2/3 of
guyana's territory but it's this massive
oil deposit offshore that both countries
aspire to control if Venezuela is able
to Annex esao it can then extend its
territorial Waters to include that's
right the oil
deposits as Maduro himself recently said
whomever has money has the power and
there's lots of oil money to be made
approximately 11 billion barrels enough
to make Guyana a top 20 country for oil
production meanwhile Venezuela even
without this new deposit still has the
largest oil reserves in the world oh
Maduro is not only a bully he's a
dictator he's a dictator to his own
people and to the Nations around him the
dispute over esao dates back to 1899
when an international tribunal awarded
the territory to Britain which then
controlled Guyana it flared up in 2015
after the oil deposit was found Guyana
sought help from the United Nations
through the international court of
justice which told Maduro to stand down
while it considers the merits of the
case Maduro chose instead to hold a
referendum which he won handily and is
now going ahead with his plans much to
the dismay of Guyana we will not allow
our territory to be violated if the situ
ation escalates Guyana could be in
trouble Venezuela is a South American
power with over 125,000 troops Guyana by
comparison has a tiny Defense Force with
only 3,400 active Soldiers with each
passing day tensions continue to rise as
all eyes are focused on this sparsely
populated jungle and the riches it
contains Mike drle Global News
Toronto ahead the new treatments for a
painful chronic blood disease and why
Canada may be the perfect place to use
[Music]
them the US Food and Drug Administration
has approved two new sickle cell disease
treatments hundreds of thousands of
people around the world mostly people of
color live with this painful life-
shortening disease far Nasser explains
how the new therapies work and what else
they could be used
for Ashley Morrow walks in the halls of
Howard University Hospital in Washington
Washington DC where Sickle Cell Research
started in America in the 40s Ashley's
had the disease since birth when I was
younger excruciating like pain you know
like wake you up out of your sleep you
know something that you really can't you
know stop or you know yeah
[Music]
and it's
tough every month Ashley gets 70% of her
blood replaced because her blood cells
in most people donut-shaped bend into
inflexible sickle shapes causing them to
pile up inside blood vessels and prevent
the normal delivery of oxygen through
the body but now a cuttingedge gene
editing technology could change
everything the United States has
followed the United Kingdom in approving
a pair of new therapies that work by
genetically modifying a patient's stem
cells Dr James Taylor is Ashley's doctor
so what this is is using a technology
called crisper cast 9
basically it's a pair of molecular
scissors that comes in and knocks out a
gene Dr Monica baa was an investigator
in the crisper Trials of 30 people one
of them mother of four Victoria gray my
life has really been transformed I
haven't had any emergency room visits
any blood transfusions I now work a
full-time job but it's far from
universally accessible the treatment
costs $2.2 million per patient we will
will not be doing it here in the
foreseeable future researchers say
expanding the therapy to larger groups
is better suited in places with
Universal Health Care like Canada what
I'm very hopeful for is our neighbors
just to the north will take uh all the
learnings that we've gotten from this
crisper approval and frankly we'll run
with it for now the treatment isn't
approved in Canada and experts still
don't know about the potential long-term
effects leaving some like Ashley
skeptical like I wouldn't just jump jump
on it a cuttingedge treatment at a high
cost but giving hope to some in search
of a cure faren Asser Global News
Washington next cracking a mystery when
the journey is more exciting than the
[Music]
destination for decades a mysterious
safe has remained sealed shot inside a
Historic Hotel in Downtown Winnipeg and
with no code to crack it people were
left wondering what was inside now as
Katherine dornian reports the wondering
is over thanks to a man who has a
passion for opening things others
can't behind the counter in the old
Lobby of Winnipeg's historic Garrick
hotel is a safe that's been there since
at least the '90s no one had ever been
able to open it until now what we can
tell just by looking at it is this dial
is not original Rick amini has been
cracking safes for over a decade and he
knows how to read the subtle cues from
the mechanisms inside the dial doesn't
always tell you what kind of lock is
inside so that's where experience comes
in because depending on the kind of lock
it changes your dialing sequence do you
start to the right do you start to the
left is there three wheels is there four
wheels sometimes there only two wheels
Rick makes a living as a Winnipeg
Transit bus driver but in his spare time
he travels All Around The Province to
open safes even going as far as
Baltimore and Las Vegas it's a lot of
patience getting the data knowing what
to do with that data that you're getting
from reading the lock dial two other
locksmiths have drilled into this safe
to try and open it but were unsuccessful
for Rick it's a fairly simple
lock and he takes just over 30 minutes
to crack
it there she goes she's open in the
Moment of Truth what's ins
side that's what we've been waiting for
anything nope nothing but a lot of dust
it's empty Rick says they usually are
it's the puzzle of actually doing it
that he cares about we're not looking
for what's in the safe we're trying to
see can we get this open without
damaging it this is the 53rd safe he's
opened this year and even when there's
no riches inside the satisfaction of
doing what no one else has been able to
do is his reward you went there you you
decided you're going to try this thing
and then you did it so it's the feeling
of completion um that you set out to do
what you wanted to do kathern Dorian
Global
News I was still hoping for some
treasure that is global national for
this Sunday night tonight's your Canada
is the second annual Steveston holiday
dog parade in Richmond British Columbia
the rain didn't stop dog owners from
dressing up their furry friends in
festive costumes some of them even got
to take photos with Santa I'm calling
christe thanks for watching Donna will
be back with you tomorrow have a good
night